For this one, I think we should use elimination. If I multiply the first
equation by positive 2, I could wind up with a positive 12 x, which would be the
opposite in sign of this negative 12 x. This would let me eliminate the x
variables. 2 times 6 x is 12 x. 2 times negative 5 y is negative 10 y. And 2
times positive 3 is positive 6. So, I have the new first equation, and then I
just rewrite my second equation right under it. So, elimination would probably
be the best here. We choose elimination over the other two because, with
substitution, we don't have any single variable solved for. And I know if I
solve for these variables, I'd have to divide by coefficients, like 12 or 10.
That could create fractions in my substitution, which would make my math more
complicated. I know graphing would be more difficult, too, because I would
either have to create tables, or solve these equations for y and put them in
slope intercept form.